accous foncé sur le plafond c'est
monsieur je vous en prie faites quoi on
peut démarrer
on ne vous plaisait pas vraiment désolé
un petit centre est un peu plus grande
salle des débats
et quand elle était jolie bons jeunes a
partout des fils julien même vous n'êtes
pas là pas génial nous est pas arrêté la
voiture s'il vous plaît non vous
descendez maintenant je m'emporte jeudi
10 aura parfois mais je pensais pas
d'ailleurs là je me regardais et je vous
trouve magnifique vous avez des yeux
subli je peux vous offrir un verre un
dîner maman quoi mais vous faites
vraiment comme ça désolé j'ai pas
l'habitude écoutez j'ai jamais passé une
heure avec un gros con vous avez une
heure dans la boue ok à la tour eiffel
s'il vous plaît monsieur la tour eiffel
c'est parti le boulet faisait dix
boulettes mais quelle poulet vous êtes
déjà vantard haut de la tour eiffel je
veux dire tout en haut non bah voyons
tout le monde critique et personne ne
connaît